foreign
[Music]
Josh Welsh president of film independent
welcome to film independent presents
um before we get started I just want to
thank Vision media uh the hfpa for
making this program possible all year
long thank you so much for your support
um I'm very excited to be here today to
have a conversation with the filmmaking
crew behind the incredible film to
Leslie the director Michael Morris hi
Michael hello and from the cast so
honored to be joined by Andrea
risborough Mark Maron Andre Royo and
Stephen Root thank you all so much for
being here thank you thank you good to
be here I love this film so much I wish
we were having dinner to talk about it
um but I can eat you want me to eat if
you want to eat and play guitar
throughout it's good
um good but okay I mean I just let's
start at the beginning Michael
um
how did this script how did you find the
script and what what Drew you to it when
you read it yeah so I I was
um I was working and this is one of
these strange things that that
came out of the blue you know you want
to think oh I've known the writer for
years and we've talked about no uh
actually Ali who is our casting director
and is someone that I had worked with
maybe seven years prior but hadn't seen
or worked with since out of the blue one
night sent me an email saying I read
this script and something about it made
me think of you and it's odd because
it's a story on its honest face of it
it's a story about a you know uh an
embattled single mother in West Texas
you know dealing with a lot of issues
and being asked a lot of difficult
questions and but as soon as I read it
like it was
I felt it I just completely felt the
character in in my bones in a way that I
now realize I had been looking to try
and find for years this is my first film
so I've been looking I've been reading a
ton of scripts to be honest and wanting
to fall in love it's a bit like in life
you want to fall in love it doesn't
always work that way you know
um and I fell in love with this the
moment I read it so I think Leslie's
story in the story of Leslie and her son
and the people uh in that orbit
I think there was some there was enough
of me that I found in each one of the
characters and each one of the their
relationships uh that they discover or
have with with Leslie in the movie that
I could that I I instantly knew that
this was a story you know that I that I
had said I had to tell
I mean you mentioned it's your first
feature but obviously you've been
directing TV for many years and doing
really remarkable work on shows like
Bloodlines or Better Call Saul where it
feels like kind of meaty
character-driven work that um this feels
like a
I'm so excited you made and stepped into
doing features now and I hope there's
lots more coming
um but this does feel like a nice
outgrowth of the work you've been doing
um
in television I have to say totally off
topic that two of my favorite things
that I've seen this year were two Leslie
an episode nine of Better Call Saul
which is emotionally harrowing like you
know incredible episode of that that
show thank you thank you very much I'm
I'm I'm really proud of that specific
episode actually
um but definitely uh I think I was
really lucky and I came out of theater
originally back in England and then in
New York um for a while and joined this
sort of Television uh party as it were
just as it was exploding in a really
good way just as we were starting to
create shows you know um the wire being
actually the first one of these that I
can remember like actively really
remember creating shows that really
started to get serious about character
and about um about uh story visual
storytelling as well and and in fact
it's my TV life has been wildly
influential on this not least because
that's how I met Andrea and Owen you
know uh uh we were doing bloodline
together uh in the second season of that
show and I think um all the aspects of
Television I think definitely inform the
sort of character work that we're doing
in this film except I've got to say that
um there is something liberating about
not having any format to be sort of
beholden to do you know what I mean and
being able to tell a story uh completely
you know completely and without uh
without certain uh benchmarks that you
have to hit and I gotta in shows like
Better Call Saul uh and many you know
those many others Barry God knows you
know you're freed from that a lot of the
time because there's there's a lot of
wonderful artists in TV trying to break
the conventions that a lot of we spent
the last 20 years inventing but even
still you know an episode of Television
is a chapter and a longer Story and
there's something really deeply
satisfying I think about telling that
whole story
absolutely
um well Andrea so Michael alluded to the
fact that you guys had worked together
before but what Drew you to this project
and and to the character of Wesley
specifically
yeah
well I've touched on it a few times now
um it was kind of strange in the way
that Michael and I met because I don't
have a lot of experience in television
at all and so he and because he was show
running a show I very much felt like I
had
he was my director in many ways and so I
I
instantly gravitated toward him because
he was the keeper of all information and
he had a sense of the larger narrative
landscape of the whole this big fast
sprawling thing that we were doing
um
so when he brought me the script
I really you know I had I had no idea
until I read it what it was going to
feel like who she was going to be
and almost instantly
um
I thought this is a story we can really
tell
and it's a story that so many of us have
been touched by in one way or another
um
and that was it really it was very
special to me that Ryan our writer had
experienced something similar with his
own mum and this was in a in a sense
something he was giving her that she
couldn't have in life
well I mean it's it's we it's such a
beautiful film in your performance is
just unbelievably powerful and and
moving and um I talked to Michael about
this on another occasion but the opening
few minutes of the film I loved and I
love the whole film but those opening
few minutes where you're establishing
who this woman is and the world that
she's coming from
it's so well it's it's so economical and
just like the brevity and the way you
set things up but it's also so moving
like just those first few minutes like
seeing what happens when she wins the
the lottery ticket seeing like the body
language between you and your son when
he's a little boy like it it just tells
like a world it really creates the world
and this character so profoundly so
quickly and I'm just I don't know if you
have anything to say about that segment
of the film and how you approached it
because the rest of the movie is not
right you have these longer scenes that
really breathe where you're in
relationship with you know Mark's
character or your son or or Steven's
character but in that first part you're
just it's it's your face and like that
scream you let out it's like quick quick
shots
well yeah as you know an independent
film we approached it you know toward
the end of the day with about five
minutes
um and it was a case scramble kick
bollock scramble is that what we say
Michael in England I can't remember the
order of the Kickball but anyway
um
you know we shot the film was it 19 days
that we shot 19 days yeah yeah 19 days
so it so
and there's something really liberating
about that I think always it's why I
love Independent films so much it's um
you're in six different places in one
day
and each time you have to approach that
that place with total abandon
and um
those early scenes where Leslie's whole
life is ahead of her really
and she finally is accepted in
her community in a way well she feels
she's going to be accepted in a
community because she can
buy every round and there's sort of no
amount of
money she can spend or
alcohol she can drink that's going to
fill this this gaping hole inside of her
and it all goes horribly wrong and so it
and so it is
of course when we were shooting that
there was that you know there's no
there's no sense of that it's important
for me not to bring a sense of that in I
learned that from it might be very early
on he was the first person that I worked
with and
he stressed the importance of
what not to know
and if you can retain that sort of
magical space for yourself where you
you can create that illusion completely
believe
that you're 27 with a young son and
about to
you know Take On The World
then then it happens and and the the
tragedy of course is that she didn't
have any of the
she wasn't equipped to make the most of
a look
and a hundred ninety thousand dollars
what a terrible amount to win right
that's just enough to screw up your life
really badly
um well Andre and Mark
um I love the relationship that who you
have in that motel and it's like you
know throughout the film you kind of
enter these different worlds and the
world that you guys create in that space
was really beautiful I'd love to hear
both of you talk about how you approach
that and and also in Practical terms how
you filmed it like I don't know I'm
assuming with 19 days you didn't have a
lot of rehearsal time or right you're
just on the set and going but um uh talk
about how how you how you built that
world in that relationship
yeah Andre talk about it
I mean I don't know I love to talk so
I'll I'll jump in and say that you know
for me it was just a lot of curiosity
about that world because I know I'm not
alone in in trying to figure out when
you're driving cross country and you see
these kind of motels and you wonder how
the fuck they stay in business like I
just don't get it I see these small
little motels and I wonder who stops
there how can they pay rent like how
much how much uh foot traffic or traffic
are they getting to uh keep keep the
doors open so I just as an actor I was
excited to go in there it's a world I've
never been uh immersed in so I just you
know I started looking at you know
pulling over walking around and visiting
these uh different uh motels and short
stay spots and uh
I just enjoyed trying to see what being
in there would feel like what it would
look like how would it uh uh how would
it uh help me shape the character and
then everything else was living in
leaving it into Michael's hands and my
co-stars and just and just playing
yeah well I think the way I approached
it was just knowing that
you know that uh his character
uh Royal had you know gone off the rails
with drugs and and not come back and you
know he was kind of this you know weirdo
but a good-hearted weirdo but not really
capable of uh
of you know a few basic things so I
somehow kind of fit
that puzzle and I could do these basic
things and right you know kind of run
interference and and and kind of manage
reality a bit for this guy
um but you know it was just uh we had a
good time you know what I mean like I I
like being in a position to react to
chaos I grew up with it so I it was
really my job in this movie was to uh
right in my role was to somehow kind of
react and uh but you know be grounded in
the face of these uh chaotic emotional
characters
um
and you know we had a good time and you
know the setting in there I didn't
realize that when every time I shoot on
sets like that because if you shoot TV
in this town you're always going to end
up in the desert one of those fucking
hotels you know one or the other and
yeah when I got there I'm like just are
there there's always like two or three
people living there and but when I got
there I was like is this office I
thought like the office was like
actually set up for whoever actually
worked at the place yeah and uh and
Michael's like no we we had septic do
that I'm like oh my God that was really
amazing because I was like half careful
not to mess things up because I didn't I
didn't want the owner to get him upset
with me you don't want the owner to get
upset with you you're right that
especially that but I would say that
just to Echo something that the uh the
the the these guys have said this is one
of the things that I think I did love
about the movie and hearing Andre say
like who who's who lives at these places
like who goes to these places I think
this movie for me anyway like the film
can do this thing of making something
invisible visible right right when you
point a camera at it and the lives that
we the time we spend with Leslie with
Sweeney with royal with Dutch and Nancy
everybody these are people that that
sometimes are invisible or considered
invisible people who are not like out
there shaking a flag changing the world
you know running races and and you know
even the setting this is a there's a
freeway and a train track next to this
place this people are constantly passing
through past just passing through as she
says at one point that's nice this is
not a place you stop and uh and I was
really excited by the idea of stopping
here
but what's what's amazing about this
movie uh my wife just saw it yesterday
at the CAA screening and and what she
said about it I think lives true it this
movie lives in the wide it lives in it
lives to let you watch these characters
it's so generous that it's the camera
stays on these characters such a long
time there's not dialogue I think the
first scene that I do with with AJ we're
in the truck there's no dialogue in it
but you know exactly what's going on uh
between these characters you know how
they're connected uh through just living
in the wide and
no dialogue and and that's what I think
is remarkable about this film is it uh
Michael was so generous in giving
everybody time to just live
in the film
I Stephen I was going to ask you about
that exact scene because I completely
agree with the way you describe it but
also it's your performance right I mean
you and Leslie both like that moment
when she works out and you're in the
truck not a word is said and I
immediately know who these people are
and like some pretty clear sense of
their history and you are just you are
here you're doing it you are pissed off
and like the way things when you get
back to the house like you're laying out
you know the conditions under which he's
going to stay there all of that it's I
mean it's in the writing I love that
there's not really you don't have to you
don't have to say anything you exactly
well at all yeah because AJ's so good
anyway and it's it's it was just lovely
to be able to do
yeah
I it's you know I also found through
none nothing obviously it's a
nothing is played for laughs but there's
a lot of humor I mean I found myself
laughing and Stephen in your scenes with
I mean I don't know there's just there's
a ton of humor throughout like when like
when Leslie you're in the house and
Andrew when you're in the house and um
the guy comes up to the window trying to
lure you out when the campfire's going
like I don't know there's just something
so absurd about that and the scenes
between you and Mark and or Mark and
Andre are also like there's something
sweet and funny running throughout a lot
of it that is a really interesting color
given how like basically dark this story
is
um but I think that you the the um I was
really lucky and uh and and you could
say smart but I'll go with lucky instead
um that everybody in the movie is so
Adept at humor everybody everybody
across the board
um and I think that's that's one of the
things that can make um mobile lived in
is when there's a little color of humor
in there because without that
I feel like you can get in towards
melodrama without really even wanting to
that you know it's like having
complementary colors when you're you're
painting you know what I mean you need
to have you need to have uh little bits
of contrast and some of my favorite
moments just personally when I watch the
film again are those kind of moments of
levity because they're they're small but
they're present because otherwise like
what are we doing it for you know what
is it when I say she's back for her
suitcase yeah oh man she's back
so much of of a character like Leslie
you know when it's not tragic it's you
know it's it they're it's pretty funny
sadly but yeah it is and there's no so
there's no kind of left there's no
Fuller deeper laughter than that and
awake yeah right yeah and everybody's in
orbit around this incredibly
effervescent human who's
addictive and of us in itself
and also yeah yeah her whole struggled
is just to you know figure out how to
take on the responsibility to clean
rooms it's hilarious I thank the Lord I
did it as a mage he says which I love as
well yeah but that's the thing she's so
connected
in so many ways she's so connected to
reality
because she's
she's in touch with the idea that
perhaps nobody's life should be
the day in day out subservience of
cleaning
she's also aware she's worth more than
that but it comes with a lot of
victimhood
you know so you're a raw nerve because
you're sober yeah yeah
just as you're like feeling everything
like a human who's inside out been
turned inside yeah
Mark Sweeney is such a sweet guy like
not that he's just a sweet guy but
there's like a
he's so he's not like you described him
as the person you know chaos bouncing
off of him which I definitely see but
with Leslie there's like this real
warmth and uh desire to understand like
she keeps fucking up and you're about to
kick her out but like there's just a a
Sweetness in your character that's
really lovely to watch
um and I'm curious like in as you were
doing those scenes building that
throughout filming with with Andrea like
just assuming again that you didn't have
rehearsal time like how did you find
that relationship was it just like in
the actual filming of it or did you come
in sort of
well I mean as soon as like I just kept
uh pretty open you know and uh
and and I realized early on that
you know that I was there to uh I mean
I'm there to help her
you know in the movie
and on some level uh I'm there to uh
also support her as a performer so the
codependency happened naturally on
screen and off and
and I you know I was able to find that
place where
you know I I was taken with her but I
think it was
it was kind of twofold in that you know
I had feelings for her but I think I was
also trying to
to correct the past so in those two
things you know equal a kind of patience
and and and kindness but it's also you
know I feel there are moments where it's
a little dangerous for that guy and uh
and you don't really know if it's uh I
don't think he's going to be taken
advantage of but it feels like at some
point he could be hurt and it didn't
really pan out that way
almost yeah I think I agree with you
Mark I think he he allows himself to get
hurt which is pretty brave when you've
spent the last however many years it's
been living in this motel and basically
keeping away from danger you know what I
mean emotionally and he puts himself out
there in the movie
and it's hard to avoid that that deep
regret that comes with or the regretful
thoughts that come with being around
somebody like Leslie
where you think if I just loved harder
if I just
it's so when presented with somebody
else I mean he's Sweeney's character's
just gone through a relationship and
then
not been able to
um sustain it and then he's presented
with somebody else who has a drinking
problem it's it
it's it's just almost irresistible
well yeah especially if if that's what's
irresistible to you you know you get you
can't fight your wiring yeah you can try
but it gets pretty boring and you
probably don't uh enjoy your life much
Stephen I wanted to talk a little bit
about
um
so Allison janny's not here but like
your relationship with her in that world
that you all inhabit again so like just
established without any backstory or
explanation but a totally believable
group of people like whatever's going on
there
um I believe these people are friends
hang out have the jobs that they have
you know until Leslie comes in and stirs
it up but um yeah it's amazing it was
easy it was easy with with those actors
and with with Michael just letting it be
you know
um that that little fire sequence that
we did was all pretty much
um improv wasn't it Michael largely I
mean I think we hit the the main points
but that yeah I think you guys
definitely lived in there and and we
already felt like a family doing that
doing scenes like that I think one of my
favorite
scenes is where you just see Janie and I
through the window and she just pops me
in the chest
um like they would do every day like I
don't like what you said it just pops
him and that's family now right there
that's that's boom that's connection
right there and uh and that was that was
easy to do with this quality amazing
actors
yeah you know to that point I think I
think um one of the things that this
that Ryan built into the script which I
think to answer your first question of
why why fall in love with this script is
he he understood in inherited like
intrinsically there's so much
storytelling happens without describing
or narrating what it is that you're
arguing about right so there's so much
history in all of these scenes the
kitchen scene with Stephen and Allison
and Andrea we really don't explain what
all the what all what's going on you
know we see them react to each other we
understand there's history but apart
from a very very sort of obtuse line
like we put more into this place than
she gave us you know there isn't really
a lot of time spent on explaining why it
is that they're helping explaining why
it is they're angry with her and and and
so to to do that for me you need a
script that allows allows the story to
to come when it comes like we learned
much later after we me Andre's character
what happened with Andre with royal we
uh you know it's only then that we
really learn about Sweeney's backstory
but to do that you need to have actors
who can who can hold on to what
whatever's going on in that silence so
that was that's really critical
I have a question
I guess this is for Michael and maybe
Andrea but I'm curious about sort of
what that is like for you Michael as a
director what kind of environment you're
creating on the set and and Andrea for
you I'm specifically I'm thinking about
this right there are a lot of scenes
that are at a kind of fevered emotional
pitch where you're just like you are as
I think Mark said like a completely raw
nerve fully exposed and you know the the
scene is going off and I'm just curious
to hear both of you talk about like what
do you create on set to enable that to
happen where you're right are you doing
like long takes with like kind of just
letting Andrea go in those moments or
well let me get that I'll answer
personal environment like and then uh so
uh for a start obviously we had no we
really really had no time 19 19 days we
keep saying but it's like that's brutal
with location moves and you know um
moving all over the place and plus we
didn't have we didn't have an
infrastructure that was big enough to to
kind of like deny the sun right so when
the sun started to go down like that's
it
um so we were always moving we were also
shooting on 35 millimeter film which
just which was wonderful and I will it's
it's one of the things that I'm so happy
that we that we were able to do but it
brings a whole other set of challenges
in terms of you know um rolling out I
was thinking Andrew the other day just
how many great scenes and performances
were stopped by rollouts not not
something we deal with on digital
anymore
um to answer your question it was also
High covered the highest of High
coverage so our set was very small and
there are a couple of things that are
good about that because the set becomes
very very it becomes like cockpit of the
plane it's not you know a place where
people casually walk through or talk or
you know hang out on their phones it's a
it became again a very special place I
think it was quiet it was usually quite
calm no matter what was going on outside
with people scrambling to get everything
done and we never put marks on the floor
which is you know we we tried lock and
cycle out amazing DP and I tried to
light the space so that there wasn't so
much
uh Ultra control over you know where
someone had to stand in order to deliver
their lines right so we tried to create
an atmosphere that was
um ready for whatever it was that that
Leslie was going to bring right and I
remember very clearly our very first day
of shooting the first scene we did had
no words it was Leslie in the bar in
that there's a little bar Montage of her
drinking near the beginning with the
Freddie King song playing in the
background and I think we all learned
very quickly from that very first thing
how explosive Leslie was going to be in
this movie and how explosive Andrea
could be uh playing her and the second
scene we shot I believe was the the
opening scene really of the film where
she's been kicked out of her place and
she's yelling at everybody and
subscribing us so those two scenes back
to back we understood the kind of
amplitude of this character of what what
she was going to give us so um I think
that set the tone
for just allowing a space where um where
that could where that performance could
happen
um
Andrew I don't know if you have anything
to add to that sort of
um
I'm
I'm
not
sometimes performing is fun in a certain
in a certain you know if you're doing
some vocabulary or something like that
or or some meaty piece of Shakespeare
that's you know quite entertaining that
has words like cuckold in it sometimes
performance can be fun but in terms of
in in terms of film
um
I always try and really Veer away from
that area
so
the more it can feel
real that it's just a totally real
situation and between action and cut
nothing interrupts that you know
um the better we were really isolated
which was which afforded us a lot as
much as it took away
it afforded me a lot internally because
I was actually surrounded by a lot of
people but very disconnected from them
so and and which is exactly how Leslie
feels their whole life there's
painful loneliness surrounded by people
in
Smoky bars you know
um
but it was really you know stepping into
all of the scenes stepping into the
motel stepping into the house with
Stephen and Alison
it was
at this level you know working with
people like this it's so wonderful
because it's just like being in a
constant playground as Andre said it's
not it's something that
we've prepared for our whole lives as
actors and you know in many ways
um and
so stepping into that in stepping into
that house with Stephen and Allison is
like stepping into a cold a pissing cold
shower of rain you know it just feels
differently uninviting
because they're
you know
Titanic talents
um and I find that more and more with
actors I love working with just kind of
just get in there you know you just
start and go and those words yeah yeah
those are some of the first scenes that
that we shot as Michael said I think I
remember actually feeling a bit on set
slightly feeling like the crew hadn't
quite bargained for this
there was a thing forgive me there was a
feeling amongst the I could feel there
was like oh goodness we're spending the
next three weeks with this
Live Wire
because everybody's known
everybody has a Leslie or has behaved
like a Leslie you know it it triggers it
triggers everyone massively um so many
of the crew members at the end came up
and told me stories about their parents
and their family members and
and
said how grateful I were to work on it
because it helped them process a lot of
stuff you know
um but it was like you know in a in a at
a peak it's like being around a
Bunchy you know she's it was
um
she's intoxicating
character yeah
well the scenes between you and o and t
gets your son are just so incredible I
mean oh my God so moving and just seeing
just seeing how like a young person
deals with that Banshee and
you know you're his mom he loves you but
he's just not gonna do it I mean it's
really and just the way you two play off
each other was so beautiful and we had
that history because we because we'd
already played mother and son before on
Bloodline with Michael so wow
and we hadn't seen each other for the
same amount of time that Leslie and her
son hadn't seen each other for and so uh
when when I saw him again he'd grown up
he didn't have a chaperone
he was a young man yeah I didn't like
he'd moved to New York you know
I was presented with an entirely
different person with somebody who's a a
it was always an incredibly competent
actor but also was and it's important to
remember this on set he's also a child
you know he was a child the first time I
worked with him
um
and so now to to sort of be able to
enjoy
going head-to-head with them and this
was just it was so rewarding it really
really was he's a lovely lovely guy well
thank you all so much for for talking
with me and film independent about it
congrats on the film I love it so much
everyone needs to go see it
um and uh thank you all again
um thank you pleasure to talk to you
thank you so much yeah thank you to
everyone
bye-bye everybody
thank you
[Music]